a final question if you can't if you
couldn't own or buy Bitcoin what other
digital asset would you buy yeah it's
great question it would probably be
digitized traditional assets writer
tokenized trishal assets i don't think
that trishal assets are gonna go away
what we're gonna see is a similar
transition from what we saw and what I
call it the analog age of security so
stocks used to be physical pieces of
paper that we would buy and sell and
transact so you wouldn't buy xlp or you
wouldn't buy carrots why no because I
ultimately don't think that they have
the same value that these other assets
have right my my belief is that stocks
what gives them value right again GDP
revenue profits etcetera all the stream
of income from a company that's doing
something assets right so everything
that makes those valuable that doesn't
change you're just changing the
technology form factor of which you will
buy that asset so you won't buy that
electronic cue stuff anymore you'll now
by that same stock of this be a
digitizer tokenized stock I actually
like those assets they're not bad assets
and I don't think that Bitcoin competes
with those assets what Bitcoin competes
with very specifically other currencies
right and those currencies even if they
change their technology form factor I
think the monetary policy is bad
bitcoins monetary policy is superior but
all of these other assets that are
quote-unquote utility tokens either
their utility in terms of they give you
access to something so they're not
really an investment it's more of AI get
utility or some good or service in
exchange so you're separating I'll use X
up here is an example simply because
I've interviewed Brad recently yep you
see no connection between what ripple is
trying to achieve with their network and
the value of x RP yes so and I think
Brad would would say this right is
rippled the software company is
different than x RP the token and I
think that part of the problem is that
retail investors have believed that by
buying x RP they have exposure to the
financial performance ripple that's
obviously not true I won't even go there
right but on top of that what ends up
happening is if ripple is successful
that does not necessarily mean that X RP
ends up being
that's for right and so also that means
that XRP could go up in value and ripple
could go out of business right
speculators could drive the price etc so
when you get this disjoint Minh
xrp and ripple or other assets that have
a similar mechanism what ends up
happening is I as a Wester actually want
to own equity in the software company
because there's profits there's assets
there's all revenues etc I don't want to
own the asset that may or may not be
there in the future and doesn't have any
underlying utility or value driver that
I can point to and say I have confidence
that that's going to last Bitcoin is
different because it's backed by the
most secure computing network in the
world